on this sunday night from stuck at sea
to home sweet home the nightmare ends
for a wave of canadian cruise ship
workers
screw this get me out of here why it
took seven weeks
to get out concerns about canada's meat
supply
fresh calls to change things up as kova
19 takes down
another facility fauci's new reality
the face of america's fight against the
virus now
in quarantine and delivering a very
different
mother's day it just takes every bit of
ugliness and throws it away creative
ways to appreciate mom
during the pandemic
[Music]
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us okay so we've all been getting cabin
fever being stuck at home during the
covet 19 crisis
for a moment though think about the
canadian crew members who've been
stranded
on cruise ships some for more than seven
weeks at sea
the federal government advised against
all cruise ship travel
two months ago and has been working to
get them back home
while dozens were repatriated today
abigail beeman has their stories
on how they managed mentally to survive
the covet 19 outbreak on the diamond
princess gripped the world's attention
as outbreaks and deaths increased on
ships countries rally to get their
citizens home
but it's been nearly three months and
crew members are still trapped at sea
according to the guardian a hundred
thousand worldwide
canada's foreign affairs minister
tweeted 75 canadians arrived home this
weekend
in total 56 days holland america paid
for a charter that flew lynn levesque
and others to toronto
she heads home to fredericton sunday
after an experience so unusual
she and some colleagues planned to get
tattoos one day
we had built up some really really
strong relationships together
and we wanted to have something to
have a memory in those last like two
weeks i was
very much like screw this get me out of
here
hunter petal says he's lucky staff were
allowed to sleep in guest rooms
and while he stayed optimistic even in
those nice rooms
self-isolation was tough by the end with
rumors flying and no clear way to get
home
i was making jokes like oh this whole us
going to the emerald princess is planned
like
t or u now around like planned like 17
like every day it would change
things looked much different a few
months ago petal works in
entertainment to stay sane during social
distancing
he kept working now for his crew we
just like hosted a tv show for all of
the crew you do like little call-in
events so we do little tributes they
call in for it
the months-long ordeal didn't turn petal
off from getting back on the job
eventually places i've seen the people
that i've met the experience i've gained
like no i'm i'm 100
global affairs is still tracking at
least 200 canadian crew members on some
70 ships worldwide and despite the
health concerns a virus presents in
closed quarters
some large cruise companies are still
planning to relaunch
as early as august abigail b minute
global news
ottawa canada's two largest provinces
are getting ready to reopen tomorrow
ontario and quebec have more cases and
deaths
than any other province in canada but
the premier say
the time is right and they trust the
public to be responsible starting
tomorrow the gates will
open at provincial parks and
conservation reserves in ontario
but for limited use during the day only
in quebec the school bell will ring
monday morning
but it's not mandatory that students
attend classes
everyone is being urged to still keep
their physical distance
by staying two meters apart and here's
the breakdown of cases in canada tonight
there are more than 31 000
active cases of covet 19 with about the
same number that have recovered
more than 4 800 people have died across
canada
quebec remains the hardest hit province
with more than 37
000 confirmed cases and more than 2 900
deaths
ontario has now surpassed 20 000
confirmed cases
adding 294 new cases in the last 24
hours
and more than 1600 people have died in
that province
a covet-19 outbreak has hit another
cargill meat packing plant
this one near montreal the company says
64 workers more than 10
of the facilities staff have the virus
according to the union
everyone else will be tested by the end
of the week
work is now wrapping up at the facility
which is expected to
temporarily close starting wednesday
cargill
just reopened its beef packing plant in
southern alberta
where hundreds of employees became
infected
one of them died and that closure
created fears about empty shells in the
meat department at grocery stores
critics say canada's supply chain isn't
equipped for a crisis like the one
caused by covet 19. ryan kessler reports
on the calls
for an overhaul in some ways pandemic
measures at pineview farms look much
like those at any other business
but the family operation north of
saskatoon is also doing something few
are
hiring we know that to sustain this
level of production we need to add more
people
so we're actually increasing our
workforce by 10 to 15 percent and if i
could do more i would
over the last eight weeks orders have
doubled at the farm which does
everything
from raising to butchering animals they
suspect the increase
is partially because of public fear of
meat shortages
the farm believes that wouldn't be a
concern if canada had regionalized
production
whereby you have a network of smaller
scale plants centralized around
large urban centers to feed those
centers and i think that's what we're
starting to see as a potential new way
of doing business
two alberta meat facilities hold 70
percent of canada's beef processing
capacity with more than 900 cargill
employees testing positive for
coronavirus
the plant shutdown has caused backlogs
for farmers
higher consumer prices and worries about
meat making it to store shelves
according to the national farmers union
one solution is to reduce dependence on
international giants
and invest in smaller companies now is
the time to sort of secure
a food system that works when
when there's a crisis a statement from
the federal department of agriculture
and agra food says increasing domestic
processing is a key priority
of a recently announced emergency fund
but one economist says it's not a matter
of large versus small
is there an opportunity to perhaps
diversify
our processing base a little bit to
reduce some of these risks
yes but he says there are trade-offs
like higher sticker prices which may
hurt demand
plus canada exports nearly half of its
slaughtered beef and cattle
and if we get too regionalized and more
expensive
we might lose some of those
opportunities and with cargill's high
river facility back online
he believes the system has bent but not
broken
ryan kessler global news saskatoon
in the coming week the country's crab
and lobster fishery
should be going into full swing but many
fishers are wondering
if there'll be a market for their
products they've been pressing the
federal government for financial support
they're also concerned about staying
safe a task that can be difficult in the
cramped quarters of a fishing vessel
david aiken takes a look at the economic
and safety challenges
facing the country's 60 thousand fish
and seafood harvesters
jason sullivan readies the atlantic
outlaw for this year's crab
fishery i fish and crab about i guess
half an hour and like since i'm a kid
but
you know full time last 20 years before
the pandemic
he thought he could fill his boat with
crab worth six bucks a pound
but now sullivan may only get three
bucks a pound
then you got your bait cost which is at
250 a pound which is so
the price of bait is nearly as much as
we're getting for for the the crab we're
catching
whether it's crab lobster sea cucumbers
or other species
many harvesters might sit out this
fishing season
because it just will not pay and then
there's the challenge of keeping crews
safe on a fishing boat so here it is
where we sleep this is
basically our bunk room sleeping
quarters for eight are cramped below
decks
and the galley is a tight squeeze if
everyone's at the table at once
it's just like a little camper really
still whatever sullivan catches
processors are ready to buy it our
retail customers this year
want significant increase in orders so
all of the orders we lost in food
service
we've more than picked up in in retail
and we actually have more orders now
than we have product
for the season and that means it's been
vital for processors like ocean choice
international to keep their plants
running
and to do that workers have to know the
company
is looking after their safety and and
that we took the action
you know in advance so that uh
you know we could operate but operate
safely ocean choice international has
about 1800 employees working in
processing plants
throughout rural newfoundland labrador
and the company says
every single worker has come back to the
job for this year's fishery
you know if we want to continue to
operate we have to be responsible about
our practices
we have to ensure people are safe and
they feel comfortable not only do
workers have protective equipment
the plants have been reorganized to
provide for social distancing
including the cafeterias workers even
get temperature checks on the way into
plants
still for those plants to be busy
fishers have to head out on the water in
the days ahead
and it's still uncertain how many plan
to set sail
david aiken global news and david will
take a deeper look into the challenges
facing the country's food producers
later tonight on our special series
coronavirus the new reality with donna
friesen
it airs at 7 p.m right here on global
the chinese city of wuhan where the new
coronavirus was discovered
has recorded its first new infection in
more than five weeks
daily life in the city began returning
to normal in early april
after a two-month lockdown the case in
wuhan
is among more than a dozen new confirmed
cases in all of china
that country reported more than 83
thousand cases of covet 19
since the initial outbreak began in
december most were in wuhan
and surrounding hubei province
now more than 4 million people have
tested positive for covert 19
globally many more have contracted the
virus but not everyone is tested
about 1.4 million people have recovered
the worldwide death toll however has
topped 280 thousand
russia has nearly 210 000 confirmed
cases
new infections there are doubling every
11 days
in comparison the uk which has about 220
000 cases
new infections are doubling at a rate of
every 29 days
but the united states remains the
epicenter of the pandemic
it accounts for more than a third of all
the world's cases
with more than 1.3 million
there's breaking news from washington
tonight an official confirms
u.s vice president mike pence is going
to distance himself from others
after his press secretary tested
positive for covet 19.
but pence is not self-isolating or under
quarantine
he is following the advice of the white
house medical team
he has repeatedly tested negative for
the virus
but dr anthony fauci and two other
members of the u.s task force
handling the pandemic are in quarantine
now
as jennifer johnson reports it shows how
little control there is
over the virus in that part of the world
covet 19 has reached the inner circle of
the white house
centers for disease control director dr
robert redfield
food and drug administration head dr
stephen hahn and the country's lead
infectious disease doctor anthony fauci
are all self-isolating further proof of
how difficult this virus is to control
we have to understand that we're riding
this tiger we're not directing it
this virus is going to do what it's
going to do what we can do is only
nibble at the edges
fauci and the others will now have to
testify before a senate health committee
this week
via video teleconference when people do
get exposed to the virus
if they know it they should self
quarantine to protect
others from getting it and that's the
process we've been
we've been doing from day one last week
two people with daily access to the west
wing
katie miller vice president mike pence
press secretary and one of president
trump's ballets
who served some of his meals tested
positive for covet 19.
that forced major changes the president
and i not only will be tested every day
but i think everyone that comes into
contact
with the president will be tested every
day white house staff are now reportedly
wearing masks
but no one at a joint chiefs of staff
meeting saturday with the president had
one on
meanwhile as americans grow restless and
more stay-at-home orders are relaxed
new outbreaks are emerging including one
in pasadena california
stemming from a large birthday party
large gatherings are still not allowed
under that state's rules i extend
caution to other families that think
well we got this
this is behind us it's sadly and
tragically not
other governors who have reopened their
states are being forced to take drastic
actions
all city beaches in naples florida have
been ordered to shut down again
after people refuse to socially distance
themselves
lawmakers still fearing this virus even
as some americans
do not jennifer johnson global news
washington coming up britain's new alert
system as it eases
some lockdown rules
[Music]
the clubs are closed but the beat goes
on for partygoers at this drive-in rave
in germany dj's pumped out the music to
the car
bound crowd socially distant dancing was
allowed
with no more than two people per vehicle
last month germany began gradually
easing lockdown restrictions but
infections are now rising
[Music]
spain is guardedly optimistic about the
latest death toll
in the past 24 hours 143 people have
died
but the daily death toll hasn't been
that low since march 18th
the daily caseload is trending upwards
though
more than 800 people tested positive
saturday up from 721 on friday
tomorrow more than half of spain will
move into the first phase of lifting
some lockdown measures
gatherings of up to 10 people will be
permitted and people will be able to
travel within their own province
bars restaurants and stores can open but
fewer customers will be allowed in
museums gyms and hotels will also reopen
two of spain's biggest cities madrid and
barcelona
remain in lockdown france is preparing
to relax
its lockdown tomorrow after 55 days
shops and schools and libraries will
reopen
but restrictions remain in most of the
countries east
including paris due to a higher risk of
infection
there are more than 136 thousand
confirmed cases of covet 19 in france
which has suffered one of the worst
death rates in europe
britain has a new covet 19 alert system
to chart britain's progress
during this pandemic today prime
minister boris johnson detailed the five
phases
level one indicates covet 19 is no
longer present
while level five is the most critical
johnson says the uk
is currently at level four so there is
still a way to go but by following those
guidelines
the government will be able to gauge if
more severe
or relaxed measures are required
that kovid alert level will be
determined primarily by
r and the number of coronavirus cases
and in turn that coveted alert level
will tell us how tough we have to be in
our social
distancing measures and johnson says if
all goes well shops and some schools
could reopen
in june still ahead why
whales are thriving under this pandemic
covet 19 could end up helping the future
of endangered marine life
the dramatic reduction in ocean traffic
is providing an
unprecedented opportunity for
researchers studying killer whales
as linda ailsworth explains it could
even help the orcas themselves
as humanity continues to struggle
through the covid19 pandemic
the world's oceans are experiencing a
rare benefit
a significant reduction in marine
traffic anywhere from 20 percent for
some deep sea cargo vessels
all the way up to perhaps even 100
percent for a certain industry tourism
cruise ships whale watching boats and a
vast network of underwater
microphones or hydrophones in the salish
sea
is recording the result what we are
experiencing right now
is actually an unprecedented opportunity
of a
quieter ocean an opportunity for
researchers like dr lauren mcwinney
who studies the effect ship noise has on
endangered southern resident killer
whales
many of these whales in the southern
resident community have never known
quiet a quiet sailor sea and so this
could be the first time in many of their
lives that they've actually experienced
such a reduction in noise that's
significant
because along with pollutants and the
scarcity of chinook salmon their favored
prey
noise from both large and small marine
vessels are their greatest challenges
because it can drown out or mask their
calls
we do anything to reduce their
efficiency or their ability to detect
prey or communicate with each other it
affects how they carry out their
day-to-day life functions and it reduces
their capabilities to hunt effectively
not only will this respite from
underwater noise help the whales
it will allow those hydrophones to
record their vocalizations
clearer and farther than ever before
a detection is so important we need to
know when the whales are here and what
they're doing when they're here and how
they are vocalizing so
um this is the type of data we can
information we can get
linda ellsworth global news
up next the creative ways canadians are
taking to thank their moms
on their special day
with the vast majority of canadians
physical distancing because of cova 19
this mother's day is heavy on phone
calls and light on embraces
that hasn't stopped us from finding new
ways to express gratitude to the women
in our lives
especially if they're on the pandemics
front line
here's ross lord with pandemic
restrictions preventing traditional
family gatherings
mother's day bouquets were dropped off
not by grateful
sons and daughters but by delivery
drivers
at a safe distance unusual arrangements
that still
pack power just ask mother of seven rose
adams
it just takes every bit of ugliness and
throws it away
gives me beauty and you need
beauty in your life
canadians are finding other ways to show
moms they care
at this long-term care home in calgary
volunteers put on a special dance
performance
for elderly residents who can't see
their families face to face
my mom loves watching us dance so
we thought other moms are probably
feeling really lonely i just love little
kids
that the two little girls are bad but
they're fantastic
canadian mothers are contributing more
than ever many frontline healthcare
staff in the pandemic are moms
so are many provinces chief medical
officers offering
poised leadership and reassurance during
a frightening time
making a full payback is difficult it's
not like last year when football star
russell wilson gave his mother a house
sealing the moment with an
[Laughter]
no embrace going to be tough not to get
a mother's day hug
actually this year i think that's
probably
the one thing that i'll miss the most
nova scotia mother anne malonson is just
glad her two children are safe
including ian who was stranded with
friends in peru
until she and other mothers lobbied to
fly them home
i have to say there was an awful
outpouring of compassion especially from
some of the mothers that i dealt with
who were you know
senior aides to mps who worked in
politicians often
offices and even some of the members of
our government themselves
plenty to be thankful for on an
unconventional mother's day
ross lord global news halifax and happy
mother's day to
all the moms out there including my mom
that is global national for this sunday
i'm robin gill we leave you tonight with
canada snowbirds
they took off again this morning for a
flight from toronto to london ontario
it's another leg in their cross-country
tour to inspire
hope during these uncertain times thank
you for watching
donna friesen we'll be back tomorrow
good night